Hmm…SQL versus NoSQL? You'll be surprised
to know that this conversation comes up
more than often than you think. Hello, my name is
Jamil Spain, Brand Technical Specialist with the
U.S. Financial Services market. And as you try to
pick a side on how you want to choose to use SQL
or NoSQL databases, I thought it would be great
for me to bring out my top five differences to
really give you the information you want to back
up your decision. So let's get started with this.
When it comes to SQL, we know that this works off
a relational database structure here. Now that
means that you're going to access all your data
points, they have to have some type of relation,
you've got to do a lot of pre-work to kind of
decide out your structure, how they're going
to relate. Whereas on the NoSQL side this is
not relational. So, we really don't have to,
I really feel for a lot of projects. I can go ahead
and get started and deal with a lot of that effort
later on in the process here. As your database
kinda checks, and gets a lot of traffic and needs
to really start to grow, on the infrastructure for
SQL servers they're going to vertically scale.
Okay. Whereas on the NoSQL side these
are going to be horizontal scaling.
All right, um and we know that SQL servers
are going to be backed by this they're going
to need more memory, more computing power to
actually process all these transactions. Whereas
horizontally with NoSQL it's all in memory, I can
keep adding secondary nodes to handle and balance
out a lot of the usage there as well. On the
SQL side when I kind of talk about my structure
it's really going to be always
about table, being table based.
I am super concerned about how
I’m categorizing my entities, my,
my tables into records and how I’m doing my
relationship. So I have to kind of think of a, I like
to say more of a warehouse kind of nature that
I’m collecting all this data here as well. And
we all know from NoSQL it is based on a document
approach. So these are really going to be documents,
all right. They can be key value hashes, this is
great for GraphQL, I mean a lot of the graphs, okay.
It's really meant to not really have any kind
of structure, it's kind of the opposite of being
a table based I can fit pretty much anything
um in this as well. So what about when you want
to access all the data? I’m going to have to use
the SQL query language to actually define all my
queries to pull all my data out so it's kind of
some pre-planning about how I’m going to access
and join my data if I’m going to normalize all the
data there. Where I feel the NoSQL is definitely
much, much more dynamic. All right. I’m really able
to, really just make my collections of these
type of documents no matter what the structure
and then I can have more freedom to let it flow
and how I want to query these items as well. So
lastly SQL great for multi-row transactions.
Where we have our tables, we have a lot of data
that we want to put in, remember the ability to do
the transactions and being able to roll back and
forth so I can really control a lot of what the,
what goes in. On the other side with NoSQL we
remember that this is going to be all unstructured.
Usually it's JSON, it's very great for working
with JSON. Let me make sure I write here on
number four that was also dynamic.
All right.So the unstructured JSON versus something that
is a very planned out, I specifically want to
enter this in as well. So that kind of ends the
features between the two, but actually I can
think of a scenario where this actually is an
"and" that should be here as well. Do we really
have to make a definitive choice of either or?
One of those scenarios goes
to the fact that I can have,
let's say I have a common e-commerce application
which is usually composed of some bit of mobile
and has some interaction with a more of a back-end,
whether it's an API that wants to kind of go
we want to commit a lot of the data. Think about
a shopping cart, okay. Let's kind of visualize
this for a minute. As I make sessions, I browse,
I do all these things, it's more like data in
transient it's not really ready to be committed
yet. So, I could see unstructured session data,
product data, what I clicked on set of clicks all
that stuff could be great for compiling into any
structure into a NoSQL site. And then as I make the
order or the transaction that could be definitely
something that I kick off into my SQL database
back in where I want to facilitate interaction
with different departments, not only is it going
to the shipping department, maybe the marketing,
maybe a couple other subsystems that I want to
document that order has been placed and kick off
a few other work streams. So, this is just
one of many scenarios that you can choose.
I'll be curious to know in the future whether you
pick a side, or you join forces to power your next
application. Thank you for your time. If
you have questions, please drop us a line
below. And if you want to see more videos like
this in the future, please like and subscribe.